welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your house definition aka the fastest
youtuber alive and this episode were
breaking down some big Flash movie news
director Andy machete who you may know
from the hit movies recently confirmed
that the film will follow flashpoint but
not in the way that we expect throughout
this video we're going to be breaking
down the news itself and what it could
mean for the film if you don't want any
potential spoilers then now's your time
to turn off as we will be talking about
the flashpoint graphic novel in full
detail including its premise and ending
without the way thanks for clicking the
video now let's get into our breakdown
of the flash news okay so if you've been
keeping up to date with the topsy-turvy
history of the flash then you'll know
it's been a very slow production run for
a film that sent it around the fastest
man alive that's that's the best joke I
could come up with Ezra Miller's flash
was introduced in 2017 s Justice League
and in my opinion he was one of the best
parts of the movie Warner Brothers had
already announced that he would be
getting a solo film all the way back in
2015 with Lord and Miller working on the
script this got canned more writers came
on board they left and so on and so
forth it did look like we may be seeing
the movie this year but after several
directors departed the project it got
pushed back to 2021
however after even more problems the
film got pushed back once more with it
now looking like it's gonna be a summer
2022 release this trouble production
schedule was murdered by the solo Batman
movie with Ben Affleck originally being
part of the project but there being a
big recast after things fell apart all
in all it's been a crazy ride
but during a panel for the Kristen
Stewart movie underwater machete dropped
that the film will be a different
version of flashpoint than you're
expecting but what exactly is flashpoint
well whether you read the graphic novel
saw the animated movie or watch the TV
show adaptation when you say flashpoint
you tend to mean one thing resetting the
universe and streamlining everything
under the guise of a time travel story
we all know that DC have had troubled
citing exactly what direction they want
to take things in their Cinematic
Universe they're going ahead with some
reboots whilst also moving forward with
parts of their original vision which
could lead to some viewers being
confused whether being a big Joker and
Batman recast the reset will allow them
to introduce these elements to
characters like Wonder Woman and Aquaman
who've both gone on to have highly
successful movies flashpoint itself
though revolved around Barry Allen
travelling back in time to save his
mother from being murdered though this
allowed them to have a relationship
together
it also sent a shockwave through time a
sort of butterfly effect that vastly
changed the DC universe as we know it
Bruce Wayne was shot in the alley
instead of his parents and his father
went on to become Batman whilst his
mother turned into the Joker their
mascara and out lantus went to war with
one another and the planet based
anihilation Superman was captured by the
government upon landing on the planet
and he was kept in a secret military
base where he was experimented on so yep
great job Barry's mum you ruined
everything
you idiot with the help of thomas wayne
flash was able to get to the core of it
all where he discovered the
reverse-flash who told them exactly how
in saving his mother he had doomed the
earth Barry left with little choice
traveled back to where it all started
and let his mother die in doing this he
created the new 52 a streamlined
reimagined comic book universe that was
sort of a soft reboot of the decades of
comic book stories that come before it
whether you like the new 52 itself or
not none of it would have been possible
without flashpoint and I believe this
will be a way to bring everything
together
discard the things that haven't worked
and start the universe on fresh footing
if you checked out my Batman set photos
video the other day then you'll know
that we went over some of the hints that
this could tie in with the Joker film
there were just a couple of clues such
as the time setting and so on that made
it seem like these had been put in place
to leave the door open I don't want to
just go through that all again but yet
definitely make sure you check that
video out if you want more information
on it as for the flash movie itself it
was stated so far back as 2017 that the
movie would be a flashpoint adaptation
but this has kind of been back and forth
with there being no mention of it being
a plastic
in 2018 when the movie was taken over by
the team behind game night it does seem
like we're back on track with the
flashpoint no with these comments by
machete but what does he mean by
different well personally I don't think
that they will have the big war and
world ending aesthetic that was such a
big part of the comic books this wasn't
really present in the TV show and I
doubt that DC at the moment would want
two of their biggest stars to face off
in a subplot of someone else's movie
they will likely have a different kind
of threat and this may be the perfect
chance to introduce the reverse-flash as
the big bad as in the source material he
was just sort of in the background
taunting Barry who knows if we will get
Jeffrey Dean Morgan as Batman as he was
interested in playing the character but
with the recent depiction of Thomas
Wayne and Joker you you just don't know
what's gonna happen
machete does have a lot of pieces to
play with and these could all lead to an
exciting outcome though I doubt you I
really doubt that we will get a female
jogger though because it's been like
three different versions of Joker in the
past four years or whatever so I think
that'll probably get left on the cutting
room floor anyway whatever happens flash
is beginning his run get it cuz you run
never mind what was I saying oh yeah
flash will begin his theatrical run in
cinemas worldwide on July 1st 2022 and
I'm very excited to see what's gonna
happen with the DC EU going forward now
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the flash movie and what you want to
see in it comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you check out our full breakdown of the
behind the scenes Batman photos which
are gonna be linked at the end if you
want to come chat to me after the video
that make sure you follow me on twitter
at definition whitey or head over to my
discord servo which you'll be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else then that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully I
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of Joker which
was one of our favorite movies of last
year and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning it's like the
video make sure you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
flash movie in the comment section below
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of January and the cell be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprise
so best of luck to everyone he takes
part this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this
I've been definition you've been the
best not see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you